[Music]
his hands were once used for battle
now they've got humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
[Music]
exactly who i am
[Music]
i want to choose my own path
live in the moment
[Music]
my superheroing days are over
[Music]
remember what i told you
[Music]
you ever feel lost
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love
[Music]
not me
what just listening
[Music]
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car
use your small inside voice in here son
there's a gun
[Music]
[Music]
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world do you get peace back
i think you might be forgetting what you
do for a living take the gun every job i
do somebody dies i'm not that guy
anymore
some conflicts require a gun
[Music]
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase you said you wanted simple
for your first job back doesn't get
simpler
dude i don't even know you
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
hmm where's the briefcase oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it was just here
we are right on settle everything that's
ever happened to you this is gonna sting
this
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you domo arigato
i'm sure you want to talk this out no
particular okay
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
then we're off
here we go
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
[Music]
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we
see and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ellie settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
i'll break the winter soldier
fear not citizen you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
knuckles you are really bad at punching
[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
[Music]
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
[Music]
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules
become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
fate
has no mercy
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i cannot escape my faint
there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
everything in here why the map this path
ferdinand magellan took the sail around
the world you know your history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found 5 billion easy
to go i think you're here because you're
your brother well you know my brother
said
tally doesn't have any friends i should
know him one of them
[Music]
you are a collector well i dabbled i
don't know
my family has been looking for this
portion for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother sayon left
one final clue
[Music]
family
oh my god i should never come out to
play with that big boy's man because
you're about to get a proper scottish
welcome
what crap
exclusively in movie theaters
bruce wayne
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
the family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
look there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strength
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruce
away
all these years
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know he's up for
delany
where are you under there
what are you hiding selena they'll throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
every night i dream about that strange
city like his calling
the target is a writer his book is
titled godslayer and the writer's name
is conglen my boss is convinced that
what happens in the story is somehow
affecting his health you only have three
days you don't want to let us down
well you're the one writing it so you
can decide what happens next
i come to kill you
show yourself
you're going up against powers beyond
your comprehension you don't even stand
a chance
the story's not done
i have to finish it
this is kimura i'm here to offer you
federal protection i know you're afraid
but you can save me right
i can help you stay alive
congratulations
you've just been erased
we've got the fbi with me we'll take
khmer in ourselves i can't let you do
that
there's been a breach you know the drill
i know what must be done
let's go grab her
game time
the mason pollard i know would never do
this something very serious must have
happened
bring him in alive
come on we gotta go green up
follower blocked mini camino's face her
biometrics and his own from the cctv
network
oh yeah was that tracking him now and
i've issued a warrant for his arrest
she needs your help i need your help
we're here for you
oh
you want me
come get me
i got you
officers down in front of the bank
automatic weapons being fired
[Music]
bank robbery suspects have taken an
ambulance
i got a cop shot gotta get him to the
hospital we're doing hostages now
i came to you for a loan you're my
brother have i ever gotten you anything
i couldn't get you out of lock
everything down
we're just trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
i have a plan
[Music]
are following these two suspects
just chill out
gotta chill out hit me up
what's going on in there
these guys are nut jobs right here it
[Music]
[Music]
hey is up big guy just waking up
does your wife know you're up eggs
i'm sorry brother
sorry that brought you into this
take me away
i just wanted things to be the way they
used to be we are trying to save you
[Music]
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother
[Music]
and get everybody home
only in theaters april 8.
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times and maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find
one out of here who even made that it's
you don't believe everything you read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
go get them
get back out there
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it sometimes you need a friend
[Applause]
nope
don't forget to land on your
send a tweet to assemble the troops
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniel's
going on here
the legend of hank
time to finish this
this might take a while
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub during
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model dash mcmahon
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up
oh my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
loretta sage is missing i'm going to
rescue her i just want her to think of
me as more than a cover mom outstanding
dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm served
by crossfit
i have snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off give me a second i can
feel them
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh oh
loretta sage getting you out of here why
are you so handsome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of proceeds
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
evelyn
i'm not your husband i'm one of the
fusion if i'm from another universe i'm
here because we need your help
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evidence
you can access
their
even the skills
there's a great evil surprise about the
many verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
ah
the universe he speaks of senseless
things is so much bigger
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
multiverse
there is no way i am the evelyn you are
looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
the old wars
cold war war on terror
he knew who we were fighting
but now the enemy is invisible
they can destabilize entire countries
from simple reach of their keyboard
[Music]
officially i can't put you on this
but if you were to go out on your own
i would need some help
i'm guessing this isn't a social pool
i'm putting together a team and you're
the best in the world of what you do
i thought this was done i'll be back for
dinner tomorrow
[Music]
hands put your gun down please five four
three two one pull the trigger or you
can listen
we all work for different intelligence
agencies
american
british
german colombian chinese
but now we have a common enemy and if we
don't stop then
let's start world war iii
so we need to join forces
this is like half the cia's most wanted
you bump i grab
i like the new team we'll take it from
here
i've got four more agents out on the
street i counted six but thanks for the
tip
i have two children
i am a normal person i cannot do this
anymore the bad guys are out there right
now you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you
no
we put ourselves in danger
so others aren't
[Music]
[Music]
355.
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately shrink bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i needed to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic knocks racing
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i needed to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity
weight coming your way you have to
launch now did he say gravity wave
trouble
we're underwater guys
uh
that's crazy
what's the plan save the mill and save
earth
ray what are you doing
let's find itself
wait for it
let's go you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
[Music]
she's out
[Applause]
so
[Music]
wake up buddy it is one o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
we'll go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who was he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
[Music]
fedex of course the federation of x's
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestruct dog
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
[Music]
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day too
just which is crazy i didn't even know
that was a thing but it's like a dog
water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy canine idea what
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
what's that
power nap you said it was clear i said
the front was clear
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stoned
we have to stop that getting onto the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons the
billionaire armstealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie star greg simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager
there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
it's
[Music]
okay i'm ready
let's go to work will someone pinch me
please is that danny francesco what's
next for you i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire
you just described me
shadow maybe do whatever i do
whatever i do
whoever greg was buying from was amongst
you last night the ukrainians
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
they're gonna kill you now we'll shoot
first then my eyes will see
what tidy you recognize your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name cover's
blown we're burnt what do i do the mood
you start is going to melt
you stop daddy francesca
what are you gonna do with that
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes do you want seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone
yes
[Music]
one day you wake up and realize you're
not sure who the good guys are anymore
you're a federal agent involved in a
secret fbi program off the books what
kind of bad stuff do you do breaking and
entering
physical coercion
you name it i've probably done it
murder
not on my menu
grandpa
gabe i've been thinking maybe it's time
i hang it up no
travis not an option
i know i wasn't a great father but i'd
like to be the best grandfather i can be
natalie doesn't need a fixer like you
i've been writing about the story for
over a year
the united states government is killing
innocent civilians under the guise of
protecting democracy
under whose orders the director of the
fbi
how many would have to die for you to
stop looking the other way
[Music]
you need to complain
you're confused about our relationship
you are my weapon you work for me
count me out you show me a little
gratitude if you want a normal life
my hand is now
[Music]
where's my family
if i find out you had anything to do
with my granddaughter disappearing
you're gonna need more men
you'll be finished before the day is
over
everything i did
is for you
are you really gonna shoot me travis
yes i will
grandpa are you a good guy
i wanna be
[Music]
was looking in your file
you're not the usual fish are you
i see that sort of behavior
as an advantage for you
it could be advantageous to everyone
including your country
want a gig
tell me more
we kidnap people
and transport them to other countries
willing to look the other way while we
interrogate them
what do you want do you know this guy
he's radicalizing young kids you got a
20 on the target
you know what's required get your hands
dirty
no restraints target's secure
the clock is ticking
somebody is really aching for this guy
there's something they're not telling us
i'm just a foot soldier they don't tell
me
more we know the more we're accountable
to
our mission is to keep the wars small
and sacrifice is meaningful
just because you're american
doesn't mean your colleagues share the
same goal as you
we have a problem
why are we descending
there's been a major shift i pulled the
plug that guy knew we were coming it's
definitely a trap
for all we know this guy's controlling
the whole goddamn thing
we're next we get ready
all i know is control in order
for some bigger picture we're not seeing
no matter how messy this gets
i'm not your enemy
we play a complicated game allegiances
change
we're officially in cleanup mode
time for plan b
so what's plan b
kill em all
extraction 10 seconds
let's do it
[Music]
oh
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
it's a curse
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now a face of choice to hunt
and consume blood
don't die
we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift
not
exactly time to let go of what you used
to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
i noticed the moment you walked in the
door
you have that extra something special
you're a real star
[Music]
i'm tired of playing to mid-sized crowds
in nashville we can do something bigger
[Music]
cheers still early y'all gonna raise
some hell or what let me grab my purse
oh my god or for dutch lee and i are
obsessed with the duchess sisters
is that her house yeah
what if i told you i got harper dutch's
address how did you get that caleb gave
it to me
oh i bet he did
[Music]
we can't just show up at our house
[Music]
so you want me to do a song with you
[Music]
y'all any good well we'd love to show
you which one of you is better oh we're
equals yeah you better drink my damn
booze
torn hearts with harper dutch is a great
idea we're doing a saltwater
this is how we celebrate
[Music]
this is weird pretty sure harper killed
hope
oh my god
harper's trying to turn us against each
other
this is my house i will tear it to
shreds to get to you too
the girls just came by for some free
advice on a whim nothing's free in
nashville is it
[Music]
kingsman world's finest tailor but now
we're going into the spy business
very clever based on true events
this will not be a war of heroes
[Music]
meet history's most evil legends
the assassin gavrilo princip weakness
throwing arm
strength
started world war one
the super spy
mata hari strength
screen presence
weakness
scarves do you forget your manners
guilty as charged
have a crazed monkey
respiratory
strength
and weaknesses
you'll have to see it for yourself
is good now yes
on december 22nd our enemies think we
are gentlemen
it's time to remind them
what the kingsmen are
nobility is born
in blood
[Music]
boys are always so messy
the king's man only in theaters december
22nd
what's a better soldier you're my dad
careful
come on let's go did you actually see my
dad's wife
yes
we looked after each other
brothers
yeah kind of like brothers
james the cleaning house
you're leaving the army with an
honorable discharge but you're losing
your pension and health care
we gave them our minds our bodies and
our spirit
and they'd shoot us up and spit us out
i just want to check in with y'all on
your past due payment message deleted
what you did in uniform sledgehammer
[ __ ]
our thing scalpel work
we operate a deep black og offshoot with
direct presidential authority
bank some decent cash put a down payment
on the house
it's not dangerous now i know you're
lying maybe i need to take care of my
family so what do you say you're down
for the cause yeah
salim mohammed mosu study pathogenic
influenza viruses in humans
we all know what one motivated radical
can do
so let's cowboy up get it done and get
home to our families you don't
understand what you're doing i'm trying
to save lives
this is only about money
what did we do mike
i've got an extraction team brown bmw x1
comply i'll do that when you confirm who
you're working for you work for me you
gotta trust me i am trying to help you
oh we're working for the president or
corporation
they train us to run their errands
kill their enemies and kill each other
it's easy to kill but it's much harder
to survive
need to get back home
home's a memory
[Music]
he's going to come after you with
everything he's got
[Music]
i'm going home
[Music]
henry
celia it's been a long time
they've opened the books on flight 127.
the hijackers had help from inside our
station here in vienna
we need to find out if we had a mold
[Music]
vic has me looking into flight 127. so
this is an interview
i thought you were here to see if we
still had that old spark
it's old friends
oh you can do better than that
told lovers
december 2012 paint me and celia's
picture i was living the dream then
flight 127 happened
the hijacking appears to have taken the
most tragic
someone in our station betrayed us what
about you they cleared me
really
if we started shouting mole that would
have been it for all of us we look at
the evidence we follow the facts are you
accusing me
we want to keep this quiet we can't
afford the embarrassment of a
prosecution if it's celia harrison i
need to know the man i send can do
what's necessary
[Music]
got her right here in front of me i can
do this clean but it has to happen now
it's the things that we don't know that
get to me
[Music]
what we had was real
wasn't it
do you know anything about wine a little
you're a lightsaber i'm chris
skye
two sudden adventures it's a sudden
adventure
[Music]
hey get away from my car man we don't
want any problems
wait wait wait
ladies you're two weeks behind on the
rent again you're not gonna say anything
explain where you were all night
i saw something on the news lisa it's
your roommate
scott i should probably contact the
police that would be stupid of me why
expecting a package
how's the knee dude i do good work don't
i
everything goes loverboy
stripping down to the studs
that's scary right i need all your
passwords and security codes
are you going to get chris so you want
me to call the police he's right here
daddy what do you want
my name is christopher decker there's a
woman in my house she's imprisoned me
against my will she's trying to steal my
identity she wants to kill me
thank god you came back chris thought i
might lose you forever i'm better now
you should have seen a look on your face
[Music]
[Music]
stay back
afraid of the dark
i love the dark
[Music]
the germans must be coming he can smell
them
who the red coast
they say he sent 100 crowds to meet
their maker
who has seen the red ghost
maybe he's immortal
eins get ready for battle
try
grenade
[Music]
it's our chance maybe your only hope
this is my home
just tell us your name
hello
come
it's been a year 16 months
you're a hard guy to get to really know
do you even want a family
i do want a family
[Music]
my name's perry i i work for grace
he wants you this address
i get
[Music]
i know who you are i know your name of
course your reputation precedes you
work for me i'm done with that really
hard
you're gonna be fun to have a route
440 grand in here
we're gonna make this exchange or i'm
just gonna take it
i mean you do have some balls
can i find out excuse me boys
do you guys mind moving out of the way
maybe somewhere over there
do you wanna grab yours i'll grab mine
where are you driving off to in the
middle of a tuesday ray
you know not much
[Music]
he got away
you know what this guy really knows how
to handle himself
so that makes things a little harder
[Applause]
oh my god
let me get you out of here okay i'm sure
you will you're here to take me thank
you
i went out of here too
one shot
can you run
can you run no but i'm gonna hover like
hell
[Music]
i'm gonna get away from all this
violence
starting
now
yeah now it's good
[Music]
we all understand betrayal some of us it
was a system maybe it was our families
could have been a stranger
nothing i love more than watching grown
men smear
[Music]
we are men we founded this country on
our backs now they want us to give up
power
willingly into the hands of people who
are incapable of wielding it
over my dead body
[Music]
what are we doing kind of like a pain at
the streets program
look i don't smack you in the mouth i'd
like to see you trying
there's some feminists who want to
attack my event
i need additional protection
she's going to be in a body bag before
sundown
no one's going to give it to us so we
have to take it
the violence you know it's gonna come
back to you it always does
you guys are professional murderers
you're coming for your blood remember
boys be nice
[Music]
it's amazing so far
we are here for this nothing which is
exactly what we're gonna do the whole
time we're here
wait a room above the water is that safe
i hope i guess
oh my god
we could be anywhere what are we gonna
do
we need to focus on surviving
how long can we last in all this
they'll come for us
[Applause]
what was that what i just saw something
this is shark
[Music]
we're not gonna die
we're gonna be okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
no wrong tv
[Music]
[Music]
another
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you